So good afternoon, everyone. It is my pleasure to welcome
you to this symposium on Inflammaging and Cancer: Mechanistic
Insights and Therapeutic Opportunity.
I am Olga Anchukov. I'm an associate professor and a program leader
at our NCI-designated cancer center at The Jackson Laboratory.
And so we're very excited to share.
We have four speakers in this session that will share their latest research
on the topics of aging, inflammation, and cancer.
And as you probably appreciate, age is really one of the main risk factors
for most adult cancers, with the incidence of
many frequent cancer types, and especially solid tumors as
well as leukemias, really skyrocketing in the
population. And this is, of course, a problem as our population is aging
faster. There is more and more cancer that are
being detected.
There are a number really of key
similarities between the molecular and cellular pathways that are shared during
aging and cancer, and many of the so-called cancer
hallmarks are also overlapping with the aging hallmarks.
The one that we're going to focus today and during the sessions is really the
impact of aging and chronic inflammation.
As you probably know, as we age, our immune system starts
functioning less well. There's a lot of changes both in the
immune cell composition as well as the activity
across all different cell types.
With age, we also see an increase of a
number of processes that will lead to a so-called
inflammaging. And so those include chronic low-grade
inflammation over time that accumulates and triggers a
number of cellular and molecular phenotypes, including the accumulation
of senescence-associated secretory phenotypes,
activation of cGAS-STING pathways, recognition of
PAMPs and DAMPs,
metabolic dysregulation, as well as
many epigenetic and proteasomal changes.
And all of this leads to secretion of a number of pro-inflammatory
cytokine that keeps stimulating those processes, as well as
many other molecular pathways.
And so this immune dysfunction of age really has profound effects on
cancer development and progression.
As we age, differences in immune cell fitness
really lead to differences in responses in the older
population. Aging alters the immune repertoire, the immune
microenvironment. Older cancer patients do not respond as well to
therapy as younger patients. Yet the problem is that most of
our current clinical trials are done in younger patients and are not
adapted to an older immune
environment.
Also, another component of aging is that many of the cancer treatments
that we're giving to patients actually accelerate aging of
cancer survivors. And so this is another aspect of aging that is
important to take into account.
So there are a number of opportunities that are currently being explored to
target inflammaging in the context of cancer, and many challenges.
One avenue is really targeting
senescence-associated sources and dampening the senescent
secretome for the use, for example, of senolytic or senomorphics.
The therapeutic windows still remains unclear.
Another approach is modulation of cGAS-STING pathways.
And again, here,
really important is the context of how do you achieve the right
balance between antitumor immunity and chronic activation.
Inhibition of the IL-6 axis
also
has some rationale. Again, here is how do we find the right
balance and the right
modes of immunosuppression. And finally, a number of
approaches are currently being exploited to try to reprogram
metabolically senescent cells.
And so as we hear the talks, we're going to have four short talks and hopefully a
discussion at the end, and some of the things I
think we would love to discuss is really how do we apply
what we're learning about inflammaging and cancer to really advance clinical
management as well as therapeutic development.
One of the questions is how do we stratify better patients?
Are there better clinical biomarkers?
When do we need to intervene
to have maximum efficacy? And what is the tissue specificity of
some of those inflammaging programs?
With such, I think there are a few things that we start needing to take into
account better in our preclinical and clinical
research. One is really measuring immune aging in both cancer models
and cancer patients in a more systematic manner, integrating some of those
aged models to design and test novel intervention strategy.
Although the aging field has come up with a number of
ways to measure biological aging, I think none of those have
really been yet exploited in the context of oncology, so we
don't know how they're applicable between
older people and cancer patients.
And I think we need to start thinking about designing clinical trials around the
biological age and not necessarily chronological age to
improve treatment of older patients.
And so with this, we're going to have four talk, and the first one is going to be
from Ari Melnick
from the Jose Carreras Leukemia Research Center.
And I'll try
to get
the slides. Ari?
Yes.
Great.
I want to thank ACR for the chance to talk to you about some of our work, and Olga
for organizing this session and the outstanding introduction.
So the title of my talk is "Role of Sex and Ancestry in Inflammaging,
Lymphomagenesis and Its Precision Therapy." I recently moved to
Barcelona from the US
to lead the Josep Carreras Leukemia Research Center, which is a freestanding
blood cancer research institute that is embedded in multiple different hospitals
and sites, and now also has a site in China.
And it's a wonderful place. These are my disclosures.
So already these discussions about inflammaging were
extremely well covered by Olga. But I wanted to mention a couple of points
related to immune system neoplasms, which is that
there is a
expansion of so-called aged B cells that occurs over time
as people age.
I'll get back to these, but these are these strange Tbet positive,
TLR7 innate sensing B cells that are
associated with aging and autoimmunity.
It's also known that autoimmunity and chronic inflammatory conditions, which of
course increase with age, are linked to increased risk of lymphomas such as
the DLBCL, which are the most common blood cancer, and marginal zone
lymphomas. And it's well established that many lymphomas have a tumor
microenvironment reflecting a variety of distinct inflammatory
scenarios that we don't really understand very well.
So I'm going to focus the talk on, again, the most common blood cancers, which are
diffuse large B-cell lymphomas. It's not a disease.
This is a spectrum of tumors that we don't yet really have a good
way to distinguish from each other.
But there have been
one useful classification is based on somatic mutation profiling, which captures at
least a number of these cases. And I'm going to talk about
the two types that
we have the most solid data for inflammatory mechanisms, which are the MCDs, which
do quite poorly, and then the BN2s, which occur especially in much
older individuals. And then I'll talk about a new kind that's not even contemplated
in this classification system.
So let's get back to those AIBCs or ABCs.
These are B cells that accumulate with aging.
They are strange. They express myeloid surface markers like
CD11c and CD11b. They express Tbet, which is
a T cell transcription factor usually.
They can undergo mutagenesis by expressing activation-induced cytidine
deaminase when they're activated.
And they can interface with various other cells in the microenvironment.
They respond to various kinds of infections, and they're very labile.
So these are B cells that kind of become activated
at relatively low thresholds of stimulation which can be problematic.
And
as the names indicates, these cells are largely autoreactive, so
they're IgM-positive cells that react to self-antigens.
And normally these populations are supposed to be kept in check, and they are the
basis for many autoimmune disorders.
And it's been shown first by Chris Goodnow that in certain B cell-based
autoimmune disorders, the B cells actually contain lymphoma somatic mutations,
indicating that at least a subset of autoimmune disorders are in fact
incipient lymphomas. And this is consistent with the fact of the risk these
patients have for developing lymphomas later on.
So,
this first part I'll make very brief talking about those MCD
DLBCLs, which are one of the most aggressive of all lymphomas and difficult to
treat.
Work conducted by Leandro Venturuti, who now has a laboratory at the British
Columbia Cancer Agency.
Summarized here, he explored the impact of two
canonical MCD mutations. One is a hotspot mutation
affecting the TLR
adapter protein MyD88. Another one is affecting a corepressor protein
called TIE2-1XR1.
Very surprising findings for us were that either of these mutations
reprogram the B cells that undergo the adaptive immune response
are called germinal center B cells.
So they form only transiently when we have an infection.
And most lymphomas actually arise from those cells.
And what Leandro found is that
either of these mutations, which are quite different, the signaling protein
co-repressor, they both result in the same perturbation, which is that
they now deviate the normal path of development of germinal
center B cells into forming aberrant autoimmune or aged B
cells. These B cells accumulate, they become clonal, they
accumulate over time, and they clearly can either lead
to autoimmune disorders or they can lead to lymphoma or both.
We don't really know these trajectories.
They're different, how they overlap, how they talk to each other.
But it does suggest that
these AIBCs may be the clonal precursor
cell for this whole set of lymphomas, which are quite aggressive.
And we hypothesized that the pathway to transformation of these cells involves
the emergence of a mutant AIBC from a germinal center reaction
after affinity maturation. And these cells, we know they disseminate throughout the
body. These types of lymphomas are, in fact
very disseminated when they present.
They tend to be extranodal, so the cells are all over the place.
And
because there's abundant self-antigen, they're continuously primed to be able to
activate. And you can imagine that with even low levels of inflammation, over time,
they're going to accumulate mutations since they express AID, and you'll eventually
get some kind of inflammatory niche that's malignant, that will lead to these kind
of hot lymphomas, many of which have a very cytotoxic T
cell-rich microenvironment unless they acquire secondarily and
later mutations that knock out MHC class 1, which happens fairly
frequently. I don't have time to get into that, but it's another
interesting angle.
But that's old. So let me go to new things.
I want to talk to you about BN2 DLBCLs, which is a newly defined entity from
Luz Staudt and others from somatic mutation classifying.
I do have a QR code I'll show a couple of times because the work I'm going to tell
you about now is coming out during this session in "Cancer Discovery,"
my favorite journal. And I'll tell you the reason why we really got into the
BN2 DLBCLs originally is because it had been noted that they have frequent
mutations of this gene called SPEN.And in my lab, we do
things when I get curious about something, that's how we choose to do a project.
And I was curious about SPEN because I like epigenetic mechanisms.
And SPEN is known to be a repressor of Notch signaling, and also
during development is important for inactivating X chromosome.
So
we explored a bit more the pattern of mutations of SPEN.
It turns out that
it's one of the founding mutations of the BN2 DLBCLs.
SPEN is mutated across many cancers, but the truncation mutants are really only
common in DLBCL. In solid tumors, they're much less fraction of
the mutations. We wanted to understand more about the mutational
context and found that by far the most significantly co-occurring
mutation with SPEN were these truncating mutations in Notch2.
Truncating mutations in Notch2 are also mainly a characteristic of DLBCL,
not found really very much in solid cancers.
And when these mutations are co-occurrent, patients seem to do quite
poorly. We put together a cohort of about 4,500 DLBCL patients that have been
sequenced, and the double mutation in this large
cohort seems to be linked to inferior outcome.
And so we thought we were onto something interesting to explore.
Knowing mutational context helps one to model the disease, and so we obviously
developed the animal models for SPEN truncation,
Notch2 gain-of-function to assess whether they're
cooperating. It was odd to me because since SPEN is assumed to be the same
thing as Notch mutations, that kind of didn't fit this co-occurrence pattern.
To make a long story short, the main phenotype that we
observed in early time points in these double mutant animals was
accumulation of AIBCs again. But these AIBCs are
not the same ones I mentioned to you before. They're actually quite different.
They're not coming out of adaptive immune response.
They come from a totally different branch of the immune system, which is the innate
part of the immune system,
which is mediated by so-called marginal zone B cells that
kind of monitor blood for pathogens.
These AIBCs were the cell type that became clonal and expanded over
time, which kind of was a mirror to some extent the
previous scenario that I mentioned to you, but through a totally different pathway.
And when the mice got lymphomas, and these lymphomas were
rich in AIBCs. And then we looked in primary human patients and
found that human patients also have the presence of the mouse lymphoma
signature and also were enriched for this AIBC-type signature.
And you can even see in Hyperion staining, the CD11c positive lymphoma
cells present in the primary human lymphomas.
So
Benedict
mentioned to me, "I noticed that in our mouse cohort that it's really the female
mice that are dying, but not the males." And we were like, "Hmm,
we usually ignore that. We don't really pay a lot of attention to that, to our
detriment." NIH tells you you have to have gender-balanced mice.
Now I know why that is because this really
matters.
And we looked in the human patients, and it turns out that the patients who are
actually dying with these two mutations are actually the women, but not the men.
So the phenotype seems to be much more severe in females.
We did many experiments, which I won't go into,
but concluded that this must be an X chromosome effect.
We ruled out hormones, et cetera. In fact, many of the patients are
quite elderly, so may have
lower hormone levels. And so we wondered, so this made us kind of
switch our thinking a bit to thinking about maybe this is something about SPEN and
failure to properly maintain X chromosome
silencing
in B cells.
One of the ways to measure that is to look at X chromosome status and methylation
patterning. And we observed indeed that in the SN2 lymphomas, there is a
reduction. It's not spectacularly dramatic, but it's there,
and significant in X chromosome status and methylation.
But we don't see that in the autosomes.
So it's an X chromosome-specific effect.
Now
this to us, I've worked in the epigenetic field many years.
This kind of mild signal that's not
very robustly confined to particular CpGs is suggestive of a kind of
stochastic effect where there's instability of epigenetic regulation.
And perhaps
there are a number of important immune genes on the X chromosome,
including TLR7. TLR7 is a critical driver of autoimmune
disorders and AIBCs. And in fact, if you look at TLR7
locus, the TLR7 locus is hypomethylated.
And so there seems to be selection for hypomethylation at genes that are likely to
confer fitness on these B cells. We
compared and contrasted the male and female lymphomas and found that AIBCs are
actually more abundant in the females.
This mirrors what happens in aging, where AIBCs are also more common in females.
We also noted that the female lymphomas had higher levels of TLR7.
And in a functional experiment, TLR7 agonists more potently
stimulated the activity of the female cells versus the male cells.
And
there was a threshold effect whereby female cells activate at low
levels of TLR signaling. Finally, we wondered if there is an opportunity for
precision therapy. There are drugs that block the TLR7 pathway.
It signals through IRAK kinases. There are IRAK kinase inhibitors in clinical
trials. Comparing female and male mice, we observed that the
IC50 for IRAK inhibitors was quite a bit lower in the females versus
males. So there's a sex-specific response to the drugs.
And we were lucky to obtain a primary human
female SN2 lymphoma that we could engraft in mice,
and we gave an IRAK inhibitor there and also observed that there was a
response to this as well, suggesting that the potential
concept of a sex-specific precision therapy for this
inflammaging type phenotype is something that may be possible,
and worth exploring further. I think there's a lot more work to do to expand on
this point. But
yeah, it's something that we never imagined.And we think we've
uncovered an X instability
phenotype that may be relevant even beyond these tumors.
As I mentioned to you before, ESTAR mutations occur beyond DLBCLs.
I think it would be a good idea to start to look for these associations.
We know that cancer outcomes are different in women in other tumor types as well.
We don't know if this is at play, but it needs to be looked at.
And again, here's the QR code if you would like to take a look and see in more
detail what's there.
I'll close with this question about ancestry, which
another sort of inflammaging surprise to us.
It's important to know that in the United States, African American patients with
diffuse large B-cell lymphomas are diagnosed at an earlier age, so they get it
younger,
and have worse survival compared to non-Hispanic whites.
Patients with African ancestry have been historically underrepresented in clinical
trials, and the studies that led to the existing molecular classifications of
the disease.
And whereas socioeconomic factors impact clinical outcome, they do not seem to
explain the diagnosis at younger age, and depending on which expert you listen
to, they may also reflect biological differences in these
patients. So, this is work that was done with Chris Flower, Gene
Koff, Yuri Fedory. It was conducted by Sanket Shah, who was a
postdoc in the lab. And Chris had published
this paper a few years ago showing that the spectrum of somatic mutations in
African Americans with DLBCL was not exactly the same as
Europeans. And the most striking finding were frequent mutations
of ATM, MGA, and SETD2, all three of which are DNA damage
sensing genes,
and which occur in more than 50% of patients.
We wanted to validate this, so we did a sequencing
profiling in an independent cohort of patients that we obtained from Paul
Rubinstein. And then Yuri has a program exploring
lymphomagenesis in Malawi in Africa, and his African patients also had the
same frequency of mutations. And so this reflects this is not something
that happens to Africans when they move to the West.
It's actually something that is part of their genetic ancestry.
We also explored the microenvironment in these
lymphomas. This is using CODEX and Luna4 staining, and the most striking
finding that we found really is increased frequency of
exhausted CD4 and CD8 cells, but especially CD4 cells in
African ancestry lymphomas. Curious.
So,
we had published a couple of years ago in "Cancer Discovery" that SETD2 help
insufficiency drives lymphomagenesis through genomic instability.
So we wondered if perhaps this inflammatory microenvironment was linked to these
tumors having genomic instability.
Staining for H2AX phosphorylation show that apparently there is a higher
abundance of DNA damage in these lymphomas, comparing the African
Americans. And then just doing single cell electrophoresis to see if
you can really see the breaks. We do see both in the murine, our
mouse models, such as lymphomas, as well as in the human cells, that there is
increased evidence of ongoing genomic instability.
So, how do you put this all together? No surprise to this audience.
We
wondered whether or not this may be linked to perhaps senescence-associated
secretary phenotype
occurring
particularly in these African American DLBCLs.
So we stained for senescence markers using various methods.
Here I'm showing you GLB1 staining.
These are four independent TMAs of African or African American
versus four European cohorts. And we observed that the
abundance of senescent cells is very obviously
strongly increased in the African Americans, and they coincide
with those mutations I mentioned to you earlier. So the mutations are present.
You see the senescent phenotype.
Looking closer at the cell communities within these lymphomas, we observed that
the exhausted CD4 and CD8 cells are actually clustered around the senescent
cells. So there's something about the senescent cells that's inducing exhaustion
in the CD4 and CD8 cells.
We
were able to sort senescent positive and negative cells from the same lymphomas and
test their functionality. I will tell you right now that these cells, the
senescence positive cells proliferate the same as non-senescent cells.
There is no growth arrest in this version of senescence, which
is not surprising in B cells because B cells specialize in
down-regulating the checkpoints that normally trigger senescence growth arrest.
If you put these positive, negative cells into mice that are immunocompromised,
they grow equally well. But you put them into mice that are immunocompetent, now
only the senescent cells are able to form lymphomas, whereas the non-senescent
cells are rejected, which together with the data I showed you in the
previous slide, suggests that immunovasion in this context is explained
by the subfraction of cells that are senescent.
We did some T-cell depletion studies.
This is either knocking out CD4 cells or CD8 cells.
If you knock out CD8 cells, it doesn't impair tumorigenesis.
If you knock out the CD4 cells, tumorigenesis is impaired, and you lose
exhausted CD8 cells as well, suggesting that the mechanism here
involves
induction of some kind of functional state in CD4 cells that protects tumors from
being attacked immunologically.
We explored the signaling pathways and
secretome of these cells. I don't have time to tell you about it, but it's the
cytokine profiles that the senescent cells secrete are not exactly the
same as have been observed and reported in cellular tumors.
So there's certainly cell context specificity in the cytokine profiles, and it's
not exactly the same. And so there may be immunological
senescence-specific functions at play, which we are exploring.
I don't have any punchlines on that.
We wondered if
targeting SETD2 itself might have a senolytic effect.
SETD2, these tumors are always heterozygous, so the lymphomas with these
mutations always are heterozygous.
They don't tolerate knocking out the other allele, which led us to wonder if we
could put these tumor cells over the threshold of linear damage that would be
impossible for them to tolerate. And in fact, we observed that they are
quite sensitive to inhibitional SETD2 inhibitors.
And
this is a clinical SETD2 inhibitor that was in clinical trials until the
company decided to change focus. We are trying to buy the drug
back so we can do clinical trials in African Americans who might perhaps
benefit from this therapy.So the summary of this last
part is that what we discovered is a novel African variant
type of lymphoma that doesn't seem to occur very often in European ancestry
individuals. It is driven by a SAS-like program that creates an
inflammatory immune-suppressive microenvironment through CD4 cells.
It's actually very important for Africa. It's very easy to diagnose.
A single histochemistry stain that costs $20 is enough to know
if the patients have it or not. If they're SAS-positive, if they're
senescence-positive, then they have it.
And this is important because those patients could be then enrolled in
SAS-specific therapy. I want to also mention that
the
studies from multiple groups suggest that there is accelerating biological
aging in Africans in general, and so the earlier
occurrence of these and many other tumor types probably reflect early-onset
inflammaaging in this population, which leads to all kinds of tumors and not just
lymphomas. And then there's a potential ancestry-specific precision therapy
approach, where using CD2 inhibitors or
immune checkpoint inhibitors, which have not been successful against other DLBCLs,
but in these model systems seem to be quite dramatically active.
So last slide. We've covered three different mechanisms linked to
inflammaaging. The first two were in the MCD DLBCLs with the
terminal center-derived IBCs, the
BN2 DLBCLs, which have female-specific
biological characteristics.
Both of these top two are linked to aging.
They both occur much more frequently in aging and especially the BN2s.
Whereas the African variant occurs apparently at a younger age, but because these
patients actually manifest perhaps an accelerated aging or senescence phenotype.
So many roads to inflammaaging in immune system
cancers and potential multiple therapeutic opportunities for intervening
and potential diagnostic approaches for detecting them.
And that's all I have to say. So thank you very much. These are our collaborators.
I point you to this website.
Hi, Ari.
Hey, Ben.
Nice to see you.
Good to see you.
I have two questions, one on each part.
So if you just mutate the SPEN1, do you get a marginal zone lymphoma?
If you just mutate SPEN1 haploinsufficient like you have in
human beings, you really don't get lymphomas. It's not enough.
No lymph, but you don't get any marginal zone proliferation or any-
You get a little bit.
NotCH2, marginal zones, you know. That's been well shown.
SPEN homozygous knockout has a marginal zone phenotype.
Okay.
But the haploinsufficient one, you kind of see
it because you know that it's supposed to be there, but it's not really very
noticeable.
Okay. And on the second part of the talk, maybe I missed this, but what's the
connection between African ancestry and developing those mutations?
This is the question that a new post-doc has asked me that question.
I think that
it's known that Africans have a number of DNA
damage sensing
hypomorphic alleles, especially P53.
But also there are papers that show multiple other genes like that, and we're
exploring if that's relevant or not.
Hello. Matt Leventhal from Dana-Farber. Great talk.
And I wanted to know, when you were looking at the differential methylation
patterns on X, do you also have
copy number and RNA in those same individuals to
confirm that you have the specific
hypomethylation on the inactive X?
Because what you could get is if you have a complex rearrangement on the
inactive X, you could also have, from the micronucleus sequestration,
epigenetic remodeling that could explain
the changes in silencing, or you could be having the
amplification, actually, of the other X allele.
Yep, absolutely. In fact,
we
have found in some of the lymphomas actually wind up losing one of the X
chromosomes.
Mm-hmm.
So I think that what you end up is having persistent hyperactivation
of the X that's remaining because perhaps X instability is
not a great thing. You have firing of all kinds of genes that may not be
beneficial for cells, and so you may actually select for loss of an X, although we
don't know how pervasive that is. Not in the paper, too late for the
paper, our colleagues in Spain did a beautiful analysis of an
independent cohort that do now show
where copy number has been
explored, that in the absence of copy number, we see broadly in the
SPEN haploinsufficient lymphomas, demethylation of X
chromosome. So now I think we're showing a few examples in the paper, but now I
can say it's across the patient population.
We should talk offline about the X chromosome inactivation or instability.
I actually have some data on that.
Love to.
Hi, this is Eji Hara, Osaka University, Japan.
So if I remember correctly, you just shown the
GLB1 gene as a senescence. But you know,
ASAB gal gene is not required for the
senescence, and I don't think that it will have a marker for senescence.
Did you check other marker, like a function marker, like a PC?
Yeah. So
for the clinical specimens, we used
Flow50G flow cytometry-
Mm-hmm
... which is a functional marker for senescence-associated beta gal.
And we also use Centrogore, which is a lipofuchsine stain
that also is when there's acidification of the
lysosomes with beta gal also
indicates that. So we tried all three of these markers.
We found that the GLB staining really correlates extremely well with the others.
And for the purpose of
biomarker use, for example, in Africa, where you'd be very limited,
I think they were confident enough in GLB1 to use in that setting.
Otherwise, my choice would be to use the flow cytometry approach.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hey, wonderful talk. So just remind me again, there's three different models you
showed. Was it the SPEN and
NOTCH knockout that where you used the IRAC inhibitor and you showed that it was
efficacious in patients?
Use IRAK inhibitor?
Yeah.
Yeah, the IRAK inhibitor was in the SPIN notch, too.
Okay, thank you so much. So, IRAK is a downstream
effector of interleukin-1 alpha and beta signaling.
Yeah.
Did you look at this to see if it's interleukin-1 alpha or beta that's influencing
the biology in that model?
We have not exhaustively knocked out all these other signaling pathways.
TLR7 is the direct activator of these
IRAK
kinases, and that's how it signals.
Okay. Understood. Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you for a wonderful talk, Ari.
Our next speaker is Sandra McAllister from
Brigham Hospital and Harvard Medical School.
Hi, everyone. Thank you, Olga, so much, and thanks for the
program planning committee for inviting me to share with you our
work regarding breast cancer. My disclosures.
But a critical challenge that we face when we think about
breast cancer care and treatment is the fact that
older and younger patients tend to have worse outcomes.
This is work conducted by our friend and colleague, Rachel Freedman, looking
at SEER data, and
since updated, looking at the adjusted hazard ratio of breast
cancer-related death. And you can see, regardless of stage and also
subtype of breast cancer, that younger and older women
have worse outcomes. They suffer more deaths.
The problem here is that although older patients
comprise, in the real world, over half of breast
cancer diagnoses and over 40% of
breast cancer-related deaths, they're only represented in clinical trials at
about 25% right now.
Middle-aged women, on the other hand, comprise
anywhere from 75% to
95% of participants in clinical trials.
And likewise, because younger patients
are facing
lower incidents, although we're hearing more and more about young onset breast
cancer, they too are underrepresented in trials.
So it poses a few challenges to trying to
understand why those outcomes are worse.
Number one, it says to me that how likely are real-world outcomes
to reflect what we're seeing in our clinical trials?
And number two, we may be missing very important opportunities for care and
treatment of younger and older patients by not focusing on
those, and also conducting research in much younger animals,
typically.
So I would like to address first, the very first question
we asked, given those differences in outcome, are breast
cancers different with age?
Somewhat simple question, very tough to answer, but I would
like to mention Dr. Adrienne Parsons and Esther Soares Colon in my lab,
along with our colleague and collaborator in my division, another PI,
Dr. Peter Van Galen, looking at computational
data and data sets that were available to try to answer this question.
So we started with an approach where we took available data sets
and looked at any correlations with age.
These are transcriptomic data sets, mainly MetaBreast and
TCGA, but we also used the Single Cell Breast Cancer Atlas
that was published
a number of years ago now by Alex Sorber's group at the
Garvan. And so what we are interested in
understanding then is if we just look transcriptomic, what are the
differences? Are there differences with age?
And then we back that work up with tissue-based validation
from clinical cohorts. And those are primarily
from a clinical study that's done right at our own institution with
Rachel Freedman, an ELEVATE study that particularly
focuses on women over the age of 70 and enrolls them into a longitudinal
study where we collect tissue and blood.
And then also two studies that were conducted in Australia,
provided by Alex Sorber's group. So all told, we
have data from over 1,500 patients to help answer this question.
Long story short, since we published it,
what we were able to do with this data is build a molecular landscape.
And I'll walk you through this.
Just kidding.
I see some fear in some people's eyes here.
But the bottom line is that this data,
looking at correlations with age and transcriptomic profiles and
CellChat analyses to look at how cells may be interacting with one another
in the microenvironment, focusing on a few cell types here, we were able to
design a landscape of
age-associated estrogen receptor-positive breast cancer,
looking at pathways that are elevated either in younger or older patients,
and this is helping us set the stage and start to test
hypotheses that we can
test out in our laboratory.
Same was too for triple-negative breast cancer, a very different
type of landscape with age. Again, looking at pathways and
interactions between cells that define those interactions in younger
and older patients. The real bottom line is that breast
cancer looks like an entirely different cellular and molecular
disease with age. And that, I think, is critical to our
understanding and how we're going to take care of patients the right way.
Very interestingly, those changes with age occur in a subtype-specific
manner,
so that the hallmarks that we chose to focus on, immune-related,
manifests in a subtype-specific manner.
ER positive breast cancer, we saw that immune responses and
metabolic processes decrease with age, while in triple-negative
breast cancer, we see a super inflamed phenotype,
hence, the term inflammaging,
that is present in older patients, and this
epithelial cell-specific phenotype of epithelial-mesenchymal
transition, where we see this great enrichment of EMT in the
epithelium.So now that we've
understood that breast cancer truly is different, we want to be able to study
mechanistically what's happening, and how we might test
response to therapy given different age.
And to do that, we had to build some models in the laboratory.
This is our overall workflow. As I mentioned, we have now
a number of clinical studies that are focusing on older women.
So we have tissues from younger and older patients that we're
biobanking, blood, tumor tissue, that we
do analyses, immunoprofiling, spatial analyses,
generate data sets, or use publicly available data sets.
And we couple that type of work with a lot of preclinical modeling
using younger and older animals, testing various
aspects of those interactions, cell-cell interactions, and functional
analyses in the laboratory. And then we're able to test
responses to therapy that we can use then, hopefully with
tissue-based validation. And so I'll take you
through a couple of the tools that we've developed.
First of all, in order to study aging, we are
essentially just using younger and aged
animals, whereby we purchase animals, we allow them to age in our
facility, and then we're using transplantable breast cancer models
injected into the younger and older animals. And for that, we use mice.
Typically, younger mice are eight to 10 weeks of age.
Older mice are 12 to 18 months of age, representing more
immunological age than geriatric tissue aging.
So the most important part of this protocol, as I just said, we age these mice in
our facility.
Everyone working on these models has to wait for a year before they can do
any given study. And we have mice on hand, but
it's a long wait. So the most important aspect of the protocol is that we have to
have a birthday party to celebrate the fact that we can now do our study.
And for much of the work I'll tell you about today, we're using an
NET1. It's a triple-negative breast cancer line.
It's PD-L1 positive, that was developed by Sandy Borowsky,
and it's done in an FVB mouse model.
So that's much of what you'll hear about today.
Second tool that's important, remember I just told you, we're injecting
transplantable cell lines into young and old mice.
Great for studying the aged macro and micro environments,
but what about the tumor cells themselves?
And one way we are trying to get at that is where we take a
heterogeneous cell line, cell population, we split that cell
line into single cells. Single cell per well.
We allow those cells to expand to
form single cell-derived populations.
Each population is then infected with its own molecular barcode.
Non-immunogenic. It's a 24 base pair piece of DNA that inserts into the
genome. And then we can study those cells individually.
They're all stored away in our freezer, or we can pool them back together,
enter them into any study, any question we want to ask,
and then get a very quick answer by a simple
PCR-based readout and
quantification of those barcodes.
So just an example. We published a number of years ago now,
but these barcodes have inter- and intra-clonal
heterogeneity, as shown by examination of a few
specific epithelial cell markers of interest to us.
We can rank those cell clones by their behaviors or their expression
of various markers. Importantly, the barcoded pooled
population has similar growth kinetics to the original parental
cell line. We haven't messed it up in any way.
And a card-carrying breast pathologist, human breast pathologist,
looking at these tumors, classified them blindly, she didn't
know whether we were studying mouse or human, as Grade 3
adenocarcinoma with stromal and intratumoral TILs.
So we're convinced we have a pretty nice model.
So the question then that was posed primarily by Milos
Basic, who's an instructor in the lab, and he is also going to be
talking later today, so
I will tell you where that will be in a minute.
But he's asking essentially, using these tools then, knowing breast cancer is very
different with age, does age impact triple-negative breast
cancer progression and response to therapy?
And that's important when we think about immune fitness and immune aging.
We've seen a variation of this curve many, many
times that we know over our lifespan that the risk
for adult breast cancer, or cancers in general,
increases. But at the same time, our immune fitness, our immune system,
peaks when we're fairly young and then does start to decline with age.
So that becomes important when what I just told you, molecular and cellularly,
disease looks different at these different inflection points.
So how might that progression and response to therapy also be
different?
So Milos used these tools. He injected the NET1
barcoded cell line into young and aged animals, and here, just
showing you very quickly, this model reflects the aggressive disease,
aggressive growth that is clinically observed with triple-negative
breast cancer in the clinic. The older mice have a slower
growth and a slight lifespan advantage.
But also immunologically, they met some of our parameters where we
see decreased naive T cells and increased numbers of effective
memory cells in the periphery.
That said, okay, this looks like a good model of immune aging.
One piece of information that was published a few
years ago by a postdoc in the lab, Jacqueline Cini, who is now
doing wonderful things in industry, is
that we knew already that checkpoint blockade monotherapy
was very
different between younger and older animals, whereby the older animals, regardless
of model, we tested five different mouse models and found
that
the response to monotherapy is significantly attenuated in
the older animals.So Malaj was asking,
given now that
in both early-stage and metastatic triple-negative breast
cancer, part of standard care is now chemotherapy
with immune checkpoint blockade that's now FDA
approved. So he's asking if we were to combine,
in this case, paclitaxel chemotherapy with anti-PD-L1
or in combination through a schematic I'm showing you here, a
treatment regimen, what would we see?
And so remember, I told you then that the young
and aged animals have different growth rates with these tumors.
So what you're looking at here is the magnitude of response whereby
we're normalizing each age group treatment
cohort to its own control. So what you're looking at here, a
higher number means a better response.
So in the young animals, we see fantastic responses with the
combination therapy. But in older animals, no significant
response. There's some response, but it's not a significant
benefit despite, again, the slower tumor growth that we had observed.
Just looking very briefly at the immune microenvironment,
CD8s. There are more CD8s infiltrating these tumors
in the old animals, but likewise, there's also
a concomitant increase in the number of FoxP3 T regulatory cells that are
typically immunosuppressive. And when we look at
characterizing the immune cells, either by flow cytometry
or we do some functional assays, what we see is
typically markers of exhaustion,
dysfunction in
particularly the CD8 T cell populations, and what we
found is that despite the aging phenotypes, peripheral T
cells can be activated in vitro, no problem, from the older
animals, but T cells from the tumor microenvironment
seem to have this suppressed activity.
So we think there are effects of aging, but on top of that, there's
something in the tumor microenvironment.
And so looking molecularly at what's going on, this is
bulk RNA-seq data. I don't need to go through all the cohorts,
but these data represent the four different cohorts, young and aged, and
doing principal component analysis, you can see regardless
of the cohort, there's a clear distinction between young and
aged. And so to get at that,
I'll try to walk you through this clearly, but what we looked at is some of
the pathways of interest to us and some of the differentially expressed genes now
between young and aged, whereby anything in red represents
enrichment in aged, anything in blue represents enrichment in young, anything with
a star is significant. We see increases in antigen
presentation, immune responses, immune checkpoint, so
like a super inflamed phenotype in the older animals,
concomitant with exhaustion. And remember I told you about this
epithelial cell phenotype, is we saw that in the older
animals, there's an enrichment of this
EMT-related genes. So with
some
human tissue-based validation, we saw the enrichment of
some of these same genes in the older women with
triple-negative breast cancer. Antigen presentation,
for instance, we see there's actually an inhibitory receptor,
HLA-E,
and concomitant in the mouse ortholog
A2Q1, enriched in older patients and
mice. Some of the same immune response and checkpoint
proteins being elevated in the humans and the mice.
And again, this EMT phenotype. You're looking now, this is single-cell data
looking at the epithelium specifically from these women and seeing
this massive increase in EMT-related genes, just like we saw in
the mice. So now what about the response to therapy?
How is that characterized in these animals?
So I won't walk you through all of this, but if we just look at general
patterns, what you're looking now at is just the young
animals and the response to therapy, so each
treatment relative to its own control.
And what we see is like we saw it with age
effects, there's a lot of red here in the same type of
pattern, suggesting that these therapies, particularly the
paclitaxel-containing therapy, is inducing an aged phenotype.
That may not be a surprise. I think we've known that intuitively that chemo seems
to be inducing some type of aging phenotype.
But that's borne out here in the molecular data.
We look at the aged animals, though, and their response to therapy, quite
interesting. I already told you that many of these pathways are already
enriched in age at baseline, just between control treatment arms.
But here, anything with paclitaxel not inducing any
significant changes.
No stars here. So paclitaxel is really having no
effect in these animals. And the paclitaxel-containing therapy, it
seems to be actually elevating, in combination with
anti-PD-L1, seems to be elevating some of that aging
phenotype.
I told you we barcoded the tumor cells as
well. So what about the clonal composition of these tumors?
I'm cutting this very short, but one particular barcode
caught our attention because it was massively elevated,
relative to controls in the paclitaxel-treated young animals.
Remember, we had this thought that paclitaxel is inducing this aging
phenotype. But that barcode in the tumors from these
animals is also enriched just with age alone.
So comparing the young controls to the aged controls, we see an
enrichment of that barcode. So these cells are being enriched in
the aged tumors. Chemotherapy doesn't
significantly increase the enrichment of that barcode in the
older animals, butBut now
from this very heterogeneous population, we have a
clonal population that is being enriched by both age and
paclitaxel
in these primary tumors. If we compare some of those genes,
what we're starting to call an age signature genes,
if we compare the expression of some of these genes,
its identity is barcode 25.
If we compare barcode 25 gene expression to the parental
pool population, we see a number of those genes are elevated
in that barcode population.
And that barcode population is
significantly insensitive to
paclitaxel. So in vitro, if we look at the cells compared to the
parental pool, it's
highly resistant to paclitaxel treatment.
And in vivo, when we inject those cells or variations thereof,
relative to controls, and treat with paclitaxel, there's no
effect.
So can we identify strategies to eliminate this
age-enriched chemo-resistant subclone?
There are a lot of data I haven't told you here, but Dr.
Spasic can tell you about in his talk, that these cells are
conferring a lethal phenotype. We think these cells are, at least in part,
driving that reduced benefit
from the combination therapy, as well as shorter
survival in the aged animals. So can we find a way to target these clones?
The way we did that was we just did a simple drug screen where
we took the Met1 barcoded cells, we treated long-term with
paclitaxel, and in vitro, that enriches, essentially,
what we're left with at the end of 39 days is a pure
barcode
25 population. And so we can subject then those
cells to a screen of over 2,400 FDA-approved
cancer-related drugs, and then look at those that will kill
off the barcode 25.
And so what we hit upon in that screen that was most effective
was a class of histone deacetylase inhibitors.
And in general, the HDACs are responsible for
chromatin remodeling,
transcription, inflammation, metabolism.
This is just very
broad description, but the HDACis keep the chromatin in a more
relaxed position so that there's actually more transcription.
So typically they're repressive, but the HDACis relieve
that repression. So we asked then if histone
deacetylase inhibitors would do anything.
And first here, we're seeing the response in vitro to
barcode 25 compared to the pool. It is slightly less
sensitive to, in this case, panobinostat, which is a
pan-HDAC inhibitor,
but nowhere near the differences we saw with other treatments.
So Milosh then asked, if we were to combine panobinostat with
anti-PD-L1, in this case,
in younger and old animals, what would we get?
We took chemotherapy off the table because remember I told you that this
clone gets enriched with age and with chemotherapy,
and chemotherapy did nothing to change the transcriptional profile
in those older animals. So we took it out of this scenario.
And so what we're looking at is panobinostat combined with
anti-PD-L1. And what you can see most strikingly is
this pink line. Those are the older animals treated with the
combination that now have a significantly extended
lifespan.
Younger animals,
combination is in green. They do have an improved response compared to
all their controls or the monotherapy arms, but nothing now like the older
animals. And when we look at that barcode 25 that I
told you is this lethal
barcode that has this aging phenotype, what we see is that the
panobinostat treatment, this is just monotherapy now.
Panobinostat does take care of that clone quite well in both young and
older animals.
Young mice still need chemo on board, though.
This is now looking at a triple combination in
young. We did not treat the older animals with this triple combination.
It's too toxic for them. But we did this triple combination, and the
young do really well when we keep chemo on board.
So
I'm going to skip that for now. But a few things that we're drawing conclusions
on from this work is that
age selects for this paclitaxel-resistant tumor cell
subpopulations that we have hope of maybe being able
to clear with the right therapeutic strategy.
Minor tumor cell clones can drive treatment resistance.
So that barcode 25 is actually not one of the dominant clones in the
tumors. It's represented at a low level, but as it becomes enriched,
it can have
massive impacts on the way the tumors respond.
Chemotherapy induces that aging molecular signature that I told you about in
young mice and is ineffective against the aging
signature in old mice. And chemotherapy is required for
disease control in the young mice.
So
that's what we've learned so far from these models.
I think the implications are quite important.
I think one of the most striking things to me that this tells us
is drugs that work really well in one age group don't
work in another, and vice versa. Drugs that aren't working well in
one age group can work very well in an older population.
So it makes me think about what opportunities we might be missing.
How many drugs are on the shelf that could be working in an older population?
Just want to throw that out there.
But then this tells me there may be a potential to improve outcomes for older
patients if we can apply some of these
clinical strategies in the right ways.And for that,
don't miss Dr. Milos Basic's talk.
He'll be digging into this work a lot more, and probably
better than I have,
in a session that starts at 2:30 today.
And I really want to thank everyone involved.
Not only the people in my lab, but critical
clinical collaborators and computational teams that have really put
so much effort into this work. And of course, the patient donors who have
generously donated their tissues, and their time, and their data for these
studies. Thank you.
Very interesting talk.
My question relates to the sequencing of treatment.
So the triple therapy for the younger
animals seemed to be quite effective.
But do you do the chemotherapy first?
Do you set up the stage for later things?
Is there a rationale, or does it not matter?
Well, we haven't done it, but I think it will matter.
I think it's a great question and an important point.
What we do wonder, given that we've seen the reduction in this
barcode 25, and we're starting to see some change in the phenotype
with treatment. What we do wonder is if we could
set up maybe a panobinostat immunotherapy treatment up
front, does that render now these cells sensitive to
chemotherapy so that we can come in at a lower dose or
a different chemotherapy to then wipe them out?
That I think is very worth testing.
Thank you.
Thanks, Sandy. It's really a great talk.
As you alluded at the end of your talk about the treatment difference
just because of the age, I'm wondering also there is this subtype
shifting from young onset versus old onset, and your
model is basically pioneering work in the triple-negative.
Have you ever thought about using more luminal to mimic the aging
and to see if there is more
effective treatment for the aged patients instead?
Yeah, I think that's an important point.
One thing we're cursed by in this field is there aren't
really models of ER-positive breast can-- Not mouse models.
I'm starting to hear of some, though, and so there's promise there.
But we can't really test that in the mouse models.
Given the dramatic changes we saw with age in the humans,
we would love to get our hands on some of those models.
I would even wonder, similar to what we heard with Dr.
Melnick earlier,
how much of this is preset? Are there changes that
presage cancer that occur with aging that
then make things...
And I think luminal is where we might see that more pronounced.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. Very nice talk.
I wonder on your chromatin sort of
modulations based on the HDAC inhibitors combinations, whether you nailed down
the modifications, so the
acetylations difference of the chromatin landscape that would
kind of explain these differences.
And another question would be about
your thoughts on B cells, rather T cells in the aging
populations, if you can respond to that. Thank you.
Yeah. Great questions. The next frontier for us is looking
at chromatin modulation. We just found this class of inhibitors.
And by the way, I don't know that
pan-HDAC inhibition is necessarily the way to go.
We want to start looking at very select pan-HDAC
inhibitors.
But knowing
what the chromatin looks like, we don't know that yet, but that's certainly the
next frontier. Your next question about B cells, very interesting.
We certainly have B cell changes with age, and we've looked at now peripheral blood
and started to characterize that.
But nothing solid to conclude yet, but we would love to
work with the right experts to really look at B-cell phenotype.
Just to follow up on that, it was a great
spatial transcriptomics profiling, which then followed again
on spatial VDJ and concluded that B cell-
Ah
... was very abundant last year at the annual meeting.
There was a plenary on
that specifically-
Yep
... so probably the next. Yeah, thanks.
Yep, definitely. Thank you.
Yeah, thanks for a really
amazing talk.
In the beginning, you showed us this really compelling
hazard ratio
curve showing the differential outcomes between the young, the middle-aged, and the
aged groups.
Mm-hmm.
And then proceeded to
show us differences between the young and the aged.
And as someone rapidly approaching her 40th birthday- ...
my question is, what about the middle-aged group?
Do you see any protective effect potentially in that group
that associates with those protected outcomes?
Yeah, we're starting to dig into that much more.
And like you say, we think based on what you just said, the
outcomes with age, the worse outcomes in young and old, we think
that's occurring for different reasons.
We think those outcomes are worse for different reasons.
Congrats on being very young, by the way.
And so we want to now start dissecting what's going on in that middle-aged group,
and for that,
right or wrong, one thought we think about is, is there a
biologic aging metric that we can start to dissect across lifespan
and start to maybe bin that middle age?
We started looking at that middle-age group, and things get really muddy.
And we don't know if that's a numbers game or whether it's just harder to
dissect, and we need to do finer age groups.
Don't know.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for a really inspiring talk, Sandy.
Our next speaker is Dr. Daniel
Zabransky from John Hopkins, and he's also a
recipient of this year's ACR Next Gen Award, so please congratulate him.
Thanks, everyone. Thank you for organizing this great session.
It's been
really cool, really inspiring to see all the amazing work coming in this
space. And I want to take a
second to say, there's so many common themes that I'm seeing in the work we're
doing, and even it's a different tumor type, but a lot to learn from each other, so
this is fantastic. So today, I'm going to talk about a project in the lab
right now, where we're trying to overcome what we think are aging-driven
barriers to effective immunotherapy in pancreatic
cancer. These are my disclosures.
And this is not surprising. Pancreatic cancer has not joined
the immunotherapy revolution. This is a very ICI-resistant tumor
type.
The lack of durable responses are there, even if you have the rare
patient who happens to respond by some chance to ICIs and
pancreatic cancer. And we're really lacking tumors that have these
exceptional responder
biomarkers. So there's not a lot of MSI-high, not a lot of
TMB-high tumors here. And you can see that they've done the trials.
These don't work. We don't use them in routine clinical practice.
And I think a lot of us are trying to figure out how can we leverage some more
knowledge about the immune system, the tumor microenvironment, to get the
responses we're hoping for our patients.
Now, the TME that I just mentioned in pancreas cancer is
a very hostile environment for an effective anti-tumor immune response.
There's a lot of complex interactions between cancer cells and
non-malignant cells. This includes a lot of fibroblasts that are making
up the bulk of a tumor in PDACs. It's very
desmoplastic and often immune excluded, so just not
many effector immune cells there.
Not just ones that are exhausted, they're just not there to be found.
This really hinders effective immune responses in this disease.
And despite a lot of great studies of the TME and pancreas cancer,
we've not done a great job of translating the findings from pre-clinical
models into new therapies or new treatment approaches for patients.
We've tried some approaches to target desmoplasia itself and the
CAFs, and we're still trying to scratch our heads and figure out how do we move
this from mice into humans and get those
better outcomes that we're wishing that we have for patients.
I think I'll,
as many others here have already shared with you, put forward the notion that
the pre-clinical models that we typically are using don't necessarily look like the
patients that we're treating. And that's really because in one
part, we're not accounting for aging.
So aging is associated with stromal remodeling, altered immune function, as we've
heard multiple times, and inflammaging, like we're talking about today and overall
in this session.
And this is very relevant in pancreas cancer.
We've seen the graphs for general cancers and other cancers before.
But in my mind, PDAC is one of the prototypic
age-associated malignancies. The average age of diagnosis is 71 years
old, with over 90% of patients being diagnosed at 55 or
older. And not just an incidence problem, but as we saw in breast
cancer, this is also an outcomes problem.
So if you look at patients with advanced or metastatic pancreas cancer,
the older patients do worse. And when I was a trainee in fellowship,
in med-onc fellowship,
my
naive thought was, well, they're older.
They're not able to get the chemotherapy that the younger patients could.
They can't get the Whipple surgery if we're talking about that.
This was a really nice study done in 2020 that controlled for those types of
things. So time on therapy, lines of therapy, ability
to go to surgery, and outcomes after surgery.
Controlling for all that, the older patients still do more poorly than younger
patients.
So when I was thinking about what to do in the lab about this and how can we model
this? And much like Dr. McAllister, we were thinking about, we need to account for
host aging to maybe model this a little better.
And we've used, again, implantable models.
So we use orthotopic injections of pancreas cancer models
to look at the tumor microenvironment and the effects.
And I'll use predominantly this cell line called KPC, which
recapitulates the major molecular and genetic alterations seen
in pancreas cancer patients. So P53 alterations, KRAS
mutations. But we've done this in multiple lines as well, different
models with pretty similar results.
So again, if we take young mice or aged mice.
Here it's over 12 months. We've done it 12, 15, 18.
Again, very consistent overall. What we find, in contrast to some other tumor types
like breast cancer or melanoma, is that primary tumors actually grow
more quickly in the older animals compared to the younger
animals. And in our first publication, we
looked at a lot of the signaling changes that happen in interactions with
fibroblasts. But as we were thinking about how do we transform outcomes here, and
what can we do about this lack of immunotherapy responsiveness in this disease?
We wanted to get a little more into the immune microenvironment and the immune
changes that are happening in the aged versus the young models.
So here I just wanted to show you, again, we get these larger tumors in the
pancreas of aged mice. But if you look at what's going on in the tumor
microenvironment and immune microenvironment level, we see a dramatic reduction
in CD8 T cell infiltration in these mice.
Now, this is what we see in our patients.
Like we told you, you have immune-excluded tumors.
So we are maybe modeling a little closer to what we see in the clinic.
Now, we again use a different model, and just as you can clone out different things
and get different behaviors, as Dr. McAllister really nicely showed in her talk.
The Stanger lab at Penn has a series of models called the
KPCY models, and they're selected for either being T cell high
or T cell low in terms of infiltration into the tumors.
Now, this is their prototypic T cell low cold clone,
KPCY-C5. You can see here again, in older
animals, the tumors grow faster in the pancreata.But even
again, what was supposed to be a cold model in young mice as it was developed,
here I can show you that total immune cell infiltration is around the same here
by flow cytometry, but there's a big reduction in the infiltration
of CD8 T cells, CD4 T cells, and intratumoral dendritic
cells, kind of hinting that the age microenvironment is a key determinant
of this immune infiltration in these models.
We wanted to also take a look, well, what is the effectiveness of
this immune infiltrate in young versus aged animals, and how is it
impacting tumor growth and spread?
So we did a simple experiment where we just depleted T cells and broadly
CD4s and CD8s. I won't show you the breakdowns because it was very similar overall,
and took a look at what happened to the tumor size and other
metrics of tumor growth in these animals.
So here I'll show you that in young mice, maybe not surprisingly, if you take
away their T cells, these tumors get larger.
So clearly there was some sort of tumor control going on with what was
there in the tumor. But in the aged animals, there's no difference in tumor
growth with depletion of T cells. Again, that told me maybe
one of two things, probably one of a thousand things if you're realistic with
yourselves, but either those T cells, there weren't enough of them there to begin
with, or the ones that were there were just ineffective at controlling tumor growth
in this model.
And it got us thinking, well, what's going on?
We know there's changes in the microenvironment, in the host, and we took a look at
what's going on in patients. So we looked at a publicly
available data set of circulating cytokines and
took a look and compared patients with pancreas cancer compared
to healthy controls, and patients with pancreatic cancer compared to all
other types of cancer that were in here.
This is pan-solid tumors, so no heme malignancies, and it's
controlled for age. And if we look at this in patients with pancreas
cancer, we were interested in this molecule GDF15, which is
high versus healthy controls and high compared to patients with other
types of cancer.
And we were interested in it because it's a molecule that kind of fit a lot of the
things that we were looking at in terms of the phenotypes we saw in our models and
the behavior of tumors we see in patients.
So, very interestingly, this is one of the prototypic age-associated
molecules that increases steadily throughout the lifespan.
It's associated with decreased T cell priming and impaired trafficking in a number
of normal physiologic functions.
It's actually the driver of
morning sickness in pregnant women, which is interesting because it's hard to
understand where it's working. And the known receptor is predominantly on brain
stem neurons, but very clearly it affects immune cells through a couple different
diverse mechanisms that are still being worked out.
But nonetheless, even though we don't necessarily know the exact receptor on every
cell type in the immune system, there's been clinical activity to develop
neutralizing antibodies against this, so we can deal with the source of the
cytokine rather than necessarily the target of it.
And it's in trials looking at trying to improve cancer
cachexia, mostly through its actions on the brain stem neurons,
but also immunotherapy resistance in previously treated non-small cell lung
cancer. So we thought this could be an avenue towards, if it's relevant in our
models, improved outcomes for our patients.
Now, again, I told you this is an age-associated molecule.
I'm showing you here its expression in aged pancreatic fibroblasts from
older compared to younger donors. It's highly upregulated.
And I guess importantly here, that I'm also showing you that it's expressed in
patient tumors. Not only in the cancer cells, we can see here around the kind
of glandular structures, but also in the stroma, in the fibroblasts, in these cells
that are native to the host, not just malignant cells that have transformed.
I think if you look at TCGA data and stratify
patients with PDAC, high GDF15 expression versus lower GDF15
expression, you start to see things fall out that kind of give you a hint
that the immune system is really suppressed in these patients with high
GDF15. And just at a more broad level, if you
estimate the makeup of their immune infiltrate by these RNA sequencing metrics,
high GDF15 really shows that you're not going to get infiltration of
all these adaptive immune cell populations that we're hoping to see in pancreas
cancer that are not there in these immune excluded tumors.
So with that, we went back and looked at our mouse models, and I think one thing we
saw is in young mice, just like in younger humans, GDF15 levels are very low.
In aged mice, those rise, and interestingly to me here, if you put a tumor
into the pancreas of a young mouse, there's no change in circulating GDF15
levels. Whereas if you put it in an aged mouse, you get an increase in
GDF15 expression, kind of, again, copying what we saw where patients with pancreas
cancer get even higher GDF15 than those that don't have cancer.
And I think we only see that if you use an age-informed model.
GDF15 is also highly
expressed in the tumor itself in addition to
the circulation. So we thought this was, again, an interesting thing where it's
matching what we're seeing in our patients, and we're able to model it effectively
by using these aged mouse models.
Then we went through and wanted to say, what's its functional contribution to
anti-tumor immunity and immune infiltration?
So if you take a young GDF15 low mouse and you administer recombinant
GDF15, you get larger tumors, and you also drive down T cell
infiltration, CD8 T cell infiltration.
If you do the kind of opposite experiment, where you breed some GDF15 knockout
mice in their cohorts and their wild-type
controls, and you wait a year for them to have their birthday party, and then you
can finally do your experiment, you see that the tumors are smaller if you have
host knockout of GDF15, and you get an increase in CD8
T cell infiltration. So again, we thought this kind of linked the expression of
this molecule directly to T cell infiltration and immune exclusion in
pancreas cancer.
Now, again, what do we want to do with this, right?
We want to move this to somewhere where we can use this knowledge to improve
outcomes for patients. And again, to Dr.
McAllister's point, what agents are we leaving on the table if we're not thinking
about age-related changes in the tumor and host microenvironment?
And I'll show you here, if you do the experiment where you neutralize GDF15 in
young mice, you'd say, "This is a loser.
You're not going to pursue this anymore.
There's no difference in
tumor size here." But you get about a 50% reduction in
tumor size if you just do monotherapy neutralization of
GDF15 in those aged mouse
models.I think the other thing we wanted to
say, is this a T cell dependent phenomenon in terms of its efficacy?
And you can see if you neutralize GDF15, but you deplete
T cells, you lose that efficacy. Again, arguing that this is
probably an immune-related effect and something that we'd want to follow up on.
And if you take the T cells, the CD8 T cells, out of these mice after neutralizing
GDF15,
what you see in terms of their
gene set enrichment pathway analysis is that those T cells from the
mice without GDF15, the ones that got it neutralized, are primed to
respond in this more pro-inflammatory phenotype.
So with that, I think I told you it's great, we can get more T cells in there.
But one problem we're really up against in pancreas cancer is that there's not a
lot of them to begin with. And you need antigen-specific T
cells to then activate T cells to go and kill tumor cells.
So we're very interested in using cancer vaccine approaches to get those
neoantigen-specific T cells and then find ways to augment their activity,
potentially through modulating TME signals, to make them work better.
And with that, I've collaborated with great people at Johns Hopkins, like Dr.
Amanda Huff and Dr. Neha Zaidi, to look at the cancer
vaccine approaches, and they developed a wonderful mutant KRAS peptide vaccine,
which covers the six most common KRAS mutant
alleles in pancreas cancer, and this accounts for over 90% of the patients that
we see in the clinic.
But I think what we've seen in the clinic so far and the trials that they've used
here is that you can induce T cell responses in the periphery.
You can get neoantigen-specific T cells against mutant KRAS in the periphery, but
we're still struggling to get them into the tumors and to actually kill tumor cells
to result in decreased tumor size.
So part of this is when you look back and you do the studies, unsurprisingly,
the aged mice, they don't respond as well to mutant KRAS vaccination.
This is what we see in terms of flu vaccines and other vaccines that we use in
an infectious disease context. But looking at
after immunization KRAS G12D peptide stimulation in an interferon
gamma ELISpot, it's diminished in aged mice.
If you then neutralize GDF15 in these aged mice, you see that you get an
improvement in the generation of neoantigen T cells.
So again, this is something that we think that maybe is doing both the activity,
but also now maybe priming is an improved function here.
But we wanted to take a look at our human data.
So this is a prior trial of a cancer vaccine called GVAX,
which is not a mutant KRAS vaccine, but a different one.
And we looked at the expression of GDF15 in patients on this
trial.
The older patients had higher GDF15, as we'd expect.
But if you look at high versus low GDF15 levels, the patients with the highest
GDF15 had the worst overall survival in this cohort.
And this was even controlling for age as a continuous variable.
So here, the hazard ratio for high versus low is about two,
not a good thing. But if you account for age just to see if it's higher in the age,
maybe it's the older patients doing worse, it drops to 1.99,
telling me that most of this bad effect is probably from the high GDF15 in our
statistical models.
So we wanted to say, what can we do about this?
I'm telling you, I think this is important.
Maybe it's influencing therapy responses.
Why don't we try this in the aged mouse models where we neutralize
GDF15, but also give checkpoint inhibitor and vaccine as
it's currently given in the clinic?
And there's a lot of groups here, but I think just to walk through it briefly,
the GDF15 neutralized cohort, you have the
reduction in tumor size we've shown here.
Dual ICI in this model is somewhat effective, but you never get long-term
tumor control.
If you combine just ICIs and GDF15 neutralization, you actually don't get
major changes in tumor size. If you add ICIs
and vaccine together, again, it's not different than just ICIs alone.
But when you give all three together, we get the smallest tumors, a significant
reduction in tumor size. And actually, two of the
seven tumors here are completely gone.
If you look at the tissue, this is actually just normal pancreas.
And I think something else was interesting, if you then look at this in a
therapeutic context, we're also seeing an increase in neoantigen-specific T
cells after the addition of neutralization of GDF15 to cancer
vaccination and dual checkpoint inhibition.
So something we're really interested in pursuing in a platform study where we're
looking at this in patients, but again, hopefully an illustration of age inform
modeling making a difference in what we're seeing in terms of therapy responses.
So with that, I just wanted to leave with some of the similar points where we think
that biological aging is a key factor that influences the PDAC TME
and can really be important for these therapy responses.
And I think considering use of age inform models is likely going to be very
important in developing rational therapy
combinations that can improve outcomes for people.
And I think, again, we're going to need a lot of these combinations to join that
immunotherapy revolution because we're up against a very tough environment, and
anything we can do to move the needle for patients with pancreas cancer is
something that we'd love to do.
And with that, I want to thank everyone that works with me in the lab and
collaborates with me at Hopkins and beyond, and thank the patients that have
participated in these studies and the funders for the work.
Thank you.
Great presentation. Congrats on a very complete and thorough story.
I just was wondering,
to what extent do you think there might be some involvement of
macrophages?
Even the T cells later on weren't really participating
in the microenvironment and being any kind of apparent role and
the known effect of GDF15 with the
macrophages. Do you think there could be some kind of link there as well?
Have you tried to deplete macrophages or anything like that?
I think there could be. As you've mentioned, it's also known to have effects on
macrophage function and activity.
So I think what we've seen in terms of abundance levels
and crude metrics of macrophage function, just
206, 163, for instance, has notShowing a major trend here after
neutralization or in the young in age.
But we're waiting on some more detailed CyTOF and IMC
data to really delve into that, because I do think they're likely contributing.
We just haven't captured it yet with our analyses.
So really nice presentation.
Question about the GDF15. There's now
efforts looking at combined GLP1,
GDF15 agonists to treat obesity.
Yeah.
Which sounds, based on your data, a bit concerning.
Your thoughts?
Yeah. I think this is one of those things of risk
in human disease, right? I
would say if you have pancreas cancer, I'd be very concerned about it based on
these data. But,
if it helps someone not have a heart attack at 50, that's a different calculus
compared to the overall risk of pancreas cancer.
I think it could be harmful, but looking at it at a
population level is probably where you have to draw the line.
I haven't had any data in this model showing that it
increases initiation or transformation of cells to kind of push
towards that initial step in oncogenesis, but rather in a kind of an
established cell model promotes further escape.
I think we need to know more, but
yeah.
So there's not a general role for GDF15
in aging immune function?
I think it's still being unraveled, but
your point is a good one and something we've got to be careful about when we're
doing these studies.
Thank you.
Hi. My question is very maybe related to the previous
question, but if I remember correctly,
GDF15 level is known to be inversely
correlated with mitochondrial function.
So my question is,
have you checked whether your observation is mainly
because mitochondrial function in T cell reducing
old mice?
No, I haven't checked that specifically.
I think it's a great thought and something we can definitely do.
Thanks for the suggestion.
Thank you all.
Thank you, Daniel, for a great talk, and congratulations again on your
NextGen Star Award.
So for those who still have a little bit of energy left on this
Tuesday afternoon,
the last talk will really focus on work in my lab, and we're going to switch a
little bit gears to go more into the molecular links
between aging, inflammation, and cancer.
So these are my disclosures. And our lab looks at this through the lens
of gene expression regulation for a process called RNA splicing,
which really enables each one of your favorite gene to generate multiple
RNA and potentially protein isoforms, some of which can have
distinct function.
And we've known for quite a while that tumors and normal
tissues have quite a different set of isoforms.
Those isoforms impact many genes that are associated with cancer hallmarks.
They can help cells proliferate faster, evade more,
escape apoptosis, stimulate metabolism, or
even impact immune responses. We've come to appreciate in the
last 10 to 15 years that many of those genes that are
abnormally spliced in tumors are actually not necessarily
mutated, but they are the consequence of a dysregulation
of the splicing machinery. Which is itself either mutated or
undergoes epigenetic or transcriptional, post-transcriptional
changes. The reason we're really focusing on RNA
splicing is that because at the end of the day, it's
really the readout of all the other molecular processes happening
upstream. So your accumulation of DNA mutation,
epigenetic changes, transcriptional regulation, all of this
converges really on RNA splicing, which is the last steps we can
really measure accurately in high throughput manners.
We're also really focusing on RNA splicing because it represents
still an untapped reservoir of novel therapeutic opportunity for
cancer that can, either targeting those novel
mis-spliced isoform, exploiting some of the splicing
vulnerability by targeting the splicing machinery, but also
weaponizing some of the splicing-derived novel peptides, which can
really constitute novel sources for immunotherapies.
So my lab over the years have mapped those splicing
vulnerability across multiple tumor types
using large cohorts of patient primary
samples and leveraging sequencing approaches, including
short-read RNA sequencing in the context, for example, of
MYC-dependent tumors, including breast cancer, as well as
brain cancers and other tumor types such as gastric.
We've really over the past five years came to embrace a new
technology called long-read RNA sequencing.
That is particularly well-suited for the discovery of these novel junctions
and potentially novel neoantigens and novel protein coding
isoforms, which really enables you to read each of the
isoforms from beginning to end without having to reassemble
those from short reads. Which
is very powerful, but also can be sometimes misleading.
And so we've applied this approach to so far two tumor
types: breast cancer, which is published, and I invite you to look at the paper, as
well as lung cancer.
And in both, we really showed that half of the isoforms that we detect with
long reads in primary patient tumors are absent from
reference transcriptomes. They're not even annotated in gene code databases.
And of those, at least half are predicted to encode novel
protein coding isoforms and generate novel
peptides. Including, for example, in our lung cancer study, we
identified a novel isoform that is important for immune signaling in
STAT2 molecules that really predicts responses to
immunotherapy in lung cancer
patientsSo as I mentioned, many of those novel
isoforms are caused by dysregulation of the splicing machinery.
Notably, in many of hematological malignancy, we see
the appearance of age-related mutation in
many splicing factors that are
gaining novel functions and enabling to detect novel splice site.
On the other hand, in solid tumors, we see a lot of expression changes in the
splicing machinery, which again regulates hundreds of downstream
isoforms. And so a lot of the work in the lab over the past
10 years has been focused on really understanding what are the consequences of
those changes and what is triggering
those changes in splicing factors.
And so the one process that we've came to study, and that's why
I'm here talking today, is really how aging itself
impacts the reprogramming of both the transcriptional,
epigenetic, and post-transcriptional repertoire.
And
following on Sandy's very elegant talk, our question was what really
happens early on before the tumors develop in the
context of breast cancer?
As you heard, breast cancer is really an age-related
disease,
and we know that changes in splicing also appear
with aging, especially in the context of brain and neurodegenerative diseases.
But when we started the studies, really very little was known about what happens in
breast tissue with aging.
And so our initial hypothesis was that we know the tumors
accumulate a number of alterations and level of isoforms and
splicing factors, but we don't really know how early this happens.
And so we hypothesized that with age and chronic inflammation,
there is a reprogramming of the splicing repertoire, which will enable the
cells to be in a more pro-tumorigenic environment.
And so Brittany Angarola, who was a postdoc in my lab at the time,
very bravely tackled this question.
And so we started by using mice, where you can have really genetically
identical animals that really differ only by age.
So we're using either mature adult animals, three to six months old, or
elderly animals, which are 18 to 24 months.
And we also leverage a large collection of human mammary
epithelial cells collected by Marc Labarge of City of Hope from various
healthy donor at different ages. So we started with mice to really
convince ourselves that age itself is sufficient to trigger splicing
changes. Here we isolated specifically from the mammary gland
two epithelial cell populations, the luminal epithelial cells,
which are thought to be the origin of most breast cancer, as well as
the myoepithelial cells, which are still epithelial but are more fibroblast-like
and really form a barrier that is supposed to
protect invasion and metastatic
dissemination. We isolated those, and then we performed
very deep RNA sequencing and long-read RNA sequencing to
identify changes in splicing between young and old animals.
And so, to our delight, we identified that age alone is
sufficient to trigger robust splicing changes in both
epithelial cell populations, with the majority of those being
cassette exon events or an exon that can be included or skipped.
To our surprise, 90% of those changes were really cell type
specific. So the changes in the luminal compartment and
myoepithelial compartment are really quite different.
Having convinced ourselves that age itself is sufficient to trigger those
changes, we then wanted to see what happens in women.
And so here we collaborated with Marc Labarge from City of Hope, who
collected luminal and myoepithelial cells from healthy women with no familiar
history of breast cancer, no BRCA mutation.
And again, we performed very deep RNA sequencing and long-read sequencing.
And here again, despite of course having very different genetic backgrounds, we
identified robust and reproducible splicing
changes in both luminal and myoepithelial
cells between cells from older versus
younger women.
Again, 90% of those changes were cell type specific, and we
would have absolutely not been able to capture them if we just looked at the entire
tissue. Very encouragingly, a subset of the gene that are spliced
are shared between mouse and humans, suggesting that there are some aspects of
aging of breast that can be modeled in mice.
We then looked really at what can we gain from doing those long-read sequencing
approaches. As I mentioned in tumors,
which have, of course, a lot of mutations and epigenetic changes,
we see a lot of novel isoforms. What about in normal healthy tissue?
And so here again to our surprise, even with
histologically healthy tissues
in those luminal cells, a third of the isoforms we
identify with long-read sequencing approaches are completely novel.
They're not present in any of the current reference catalog,
suggesting, again, a really very deep reprogramming of the splicing
repertoire with age. So what are the genes that are
affected by splicing? Interestingly, the top category of genes
that were spliced with age were associated with DNA repair genes,
and so we're currently investigating a number of those.
Our two working hypothesis that are that either with
age, those DNA repair gene isoforms actually make the
machinery more efficient at repairing
damages and actually preventing aging or, on the other hand,
that this is associated with the decline
we see with fitness and the
accumulation of mutation. And so stay tuned for our
findings.
We then asked the question, are those changes actually relevant to
anything we see in human breast tumors?
So here we focus on luminal A and B breast cancer subtypes,
which really represent the majority of
breast cancers in older women. And we identify that
of thissplicing events we see in older luminal
cells. There is a subset of 219 that we also see
in older breast tumors, suggesting that the cells that gave rise to
this tumor already had this age-related alteration.
So how are those alterations triggered?
We think that at least in part, this is due to changes in splicing factor
expression. In older luminal cell, we see decreased
expression of a splicing factor called quaking, and we also see that
in breast tumors across the entire Cancer Genome Atlas projects,
almost half of the tumors have a decreased expression of quaking, which may in
part explain some of the splicing changes.
So in summary for this part,
I hope you'll remember that aging really triggers not
only accumulation of mutations, epigenetic changes, but also
downstream impacts the expression of RNA isoforms,
as well as the regulation of those isoform at the splicing level.
We see a really striking similarities between aging and cancer.
And there are a number of remaining questions, really.
How is this regulating? How does this connect to other cancer hallmarks, including
epigenetic?
How are those splicing changes regulated, and what are their functional
consequences? And of course, what happens in other cell
types? As you've heard, the epithelial cells are really critical for
transformation of solid tumors, but of course, they live in an environment
of stromal and immune cells, which are equally important.
And so to start addressing this question,
in a paper published last year, we profiled
both the transcriptome and epigenome of mammary
cell types within the mammary glands of older and younger mice,
as well as done spatial transcriptomics.
And just to quickly summarize our findings, our atlas, which we hope will
be useful to other researchers, uncovered that with age, we
see in the mammary gland, we see changes in cell proportional, changes in gene
expression, as well as changes in chromatin accessibility
across all different cell type compartments, both the epithelial cells, stromal
cells and immune cells.
Strikingly, across all compartment, we've seen increased cell plasticity
and loss of cell identity. So the epithelial cells become less
epithelial. The luminal and myoepithelial start merging together.
We see increased expression of genes with tumor suppressor activity and
increased expression of pro-inflammatory molecules.
So if you're interested to look more into this, we invite you to look in
the paper. And so for the sake of time, I'll just give you two examples of
really very exciting behaviors we identified.
So in the stromal compartment, we see changes in the number
of fibroblasts with age, but also in the types of fibroblasts.
For example, this fibroblast C2 population here in yellow really
increases in magnitude in aged animals.
Those actually start expressing
different cell markers. They become less fibroblast-like.
They lose some of the fibronectin expression and gain some of the
collagen expression. They also start expressing some pro-inflammatory
molecules, and they may be more adipocyte-like.
And finally, they also start become expressing more of the
senescence markers, which is similar to what has been described in other
tissue types.
In the immune compartment, we see, of course, a very dramatic
remodeling of the immune landscape of a decrease in naive CD4 and
CD8 cells,
as well as an increase in the numbers of granzyme K positive cells, gamma
delta MAIT cells, and memory CD4 and NK
cells. The largest population that increases with age in the mammary gland are
really those granzyme K positive cells, which have also been
seen in other tissues of age, those tissue resident
cells. They express markers of inflammation,
pro-inflammatory molecules, as well as some
cytokines such as CCL5, which I think Sandy also saw in some of
her
models, and really suggesting a very important
remodeling of the immune compartment.
Finally, we use spatial transcriptomic to really confirm the presence of the
tissue-resident immune cells. So here we profiled using
the Visium platform, mammary glands from young and old animals
identifying multiple cell populations.
And very excitingly, we were able to confirm
that those granzyme K positive cells, but also
some of the other
gamma delta T cells and PDCD1 positive cells, are
really enriched in the tissue, and they're enriched in
clusters that are epithelial. So they're really interacting with
the aged epithelial cells.
Finally, we looked whether those differentially expressed genes that we
see with age in mouse mammary cells
are also found in human breast tumors.
And for example, on the left, we see decreased expression of
RUNX tumor suppressor with age, both in mouse mammary cells
and in human breast tumors from the luminal subtypes.
We see expression of other markers, such as increased expression
of MX3A, which is an RNA binding proteins, and
expression of FNDC4.
So in summary,
our profile in epigenetic and transcriptomic profiling
identified changes in cell composition in the mammary gland, as well as
gene expression and chromatin changes that really are along this
theme of loss of lineage fidelity.
And importantly, there was an overlap between the aging signature we
find in those mouse models with some of the genes we
see upregulated or downregulated in human
breastThe caveat of this work
for our lab in the context of studying isoforms is that most of the
single-cell approaches do not allow you to measure splicing.
They really read the 3' UTR end of genes.
And thus,
when we're thinking about RNA splicing and identifying potentially
those novel peptides, we really have no idea to know where they come from.
We don't know which cells express those isoforms and how they're interacting.
And so we're very fortunate to have been really working on this,
supported by several grants over the past few years,
to couple both single-cell and spatial approaches with long-read sequencing so
that we can detect those isoforms in the context of
aging as well as tumor cells.
And so very excitingly, that technology is now finally working
and fine for prime time, and so we can identify within mammary tissues
isoforms that are, for example, cell type specific.
So pyruvate kinase isoform can be expressed at a muscle-- One
isoform is expressed in muscle cells, the other one is expressed in epithelial
cells.
And on the other hand, there are a number of immune molecule, for example,
CD59b which have an isoforms that has
either an additional exon or skipped exons and have
different usage in different cell type clusters between young and old.
And so we're very excited to apply this to really understand how both
aging and transformation impacts the isoform repertoire
inside too.
We're studying how those
changes that impact DNA repair gene impacts cancer
initiation. We're also looking at
syndromes that are associated with accelerated aging, for example, BRCA
mutations, and how those impact the
splicing repertoire. And our goal is to
develop novel strategies not only to stratify patients, but hopefully at
some point to target those pre-neoplastic cells.
And so finally, while most of our work has focused really on the
epithelial cells, we're very interested in understanding how the
interactions between the epithelial and immune cells is
modulated for splicing. And so in that realm, we have
identified a number of molecules that impact immune
responses in epithelial cells. For example, in collaboration with Dr.
Paluca at JAX, we identified a novel STAT2 isoform
that really impacts interferon signaling of lung adenocarcinoma cells
and predicts PD-L1 responses in human
patients.
We've also identified and together with Tony Vella at
UConn,
a number of splicing factors that impact T cell fate and response to
antigen receptor stimulation and can be modulated for
splicing. And finally, if you still have some energy and want to work for the
poster boards,
Toufic is presenting a poster on aging of
epithelial cells in the context of lung cancer and lung
dysfunctions.
So I hope I convince you that splicing is really worth
exploring and that you will all look at splicing of your favorite genes.
I think it has a lot of potential, not only to understand tumor
progression, but hopefully to really
develop novel strategy not only for early cancer detection.
And so with this, I want to thank all the people in the lab and our sources of
funding and collaborators. And if you're interested in long-read sequencing, we're
organizing a workshop in Farmington,
Connecticut in May, and so you're welcome to join.
Thank you for your time, and I'll be happy to take a couple of questions.
Hi. Great. Thank you very much. Very nice talk.
So I have a
couple questions. My first question is the first part, the splicing factor.
Do you think that kind of splicing alteration, it also
occurred in,
for example, obesity associated cancer or smoking associated cancer,
not aging related cancer? Do you see the similar phenotype?
That's a great question. I don't know that it has been ever looked at, and
I don't know how you would, I guess, uncouple in some of those
larger data sets, the obesity, for example, from age-associated
cancer. I think there are some commonalities,
but I think it's definitely worth looking at.
Okay, great. Thank you. So our question is, so in
the second part of your talk, you shown that some
senescence marking of some fibroblast.
But did you see really
senescence phenotype? Because senescence is not just expressing
a several marker.
Basically, that is a stable cell cycle.
So I'm just wondering whether that really senescence or just expressing
senescence associated gene.
We've used some of the scores, senescence score for expression
of senescence markers. I agree, senescence is a very complicated
and multifaceted phenotype, and I think we've tried to stay away of
that. We're not senescence expert.
If you have suggestion really how to accurately measure senescence
in different tissues, I'm all ears.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, and let's thank again all the speakers from this session.
Thank you for your attention, and I hope you have a wonderful end of the meeting.